all right now 5 56 on your wednesday
morning we have the nightmare on nellis
part two viewer crystal wrote in you may
remember about the pedestrian crosswalk
at nellis and cetus between bonanza and
stuart
she wrote the crosswalk is not marked
well people ignore the fact you're there
they need to put flashing lights mark
the crosswalk she said she's been
almost hit several times by speeding
drivers and she points out
it is a clearly marked school zone well
crystal
i did hear back from tony ileo with the
nevada department of transportation he
confirmed that the intersection
is set to be re-striped as part of that
10-mile
nellis repaving project and he added
that an inspection of the school zone
flashing light shows
they're not working i also got a tip
from another viewer mark that nellis and
cedar is listed as a future
city of las vegas project on a regional
transportation commission website so i'm
checking with them
we'll stay on top of that school zone
signal make sure it gets back working
again
crystal see what you started uh tony as
always thank you for following up mark
thank you for writing in two buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight
at eight news now dot com